I have to tell you about quite a wild
thing that's going on in the area of
protecting big business excusing the
wrongdoing of big business making it
easier for big corporations to just
avoid responsibility for the things that
they sometimes do wrong and the ways
that big business sometimes hurts people
some of you may be familiar with the
term tort reform now if you ask
Advocates of tort reform what they mean
they will talk to you about judicial
wrongdoing too many lawsuits frivolous
lawsuits outrageous settlements being
given to plaintiffs who sue corporations
that's what the tort reform people will
tell you but at its core a huge part of
tort reform is making it harder for
individuals who were wronged by a
business a corporation did something
wrong the individual wants to now hold
the business accountable tort reform
would make it harder for individuals to
the fullest extent of the law and their
responsibility to hold corporate
stations accountable now as I've said
before
sometimes people get mad that lawyers in
class action lawsuits or mass tort cases
make a lot of money they make too much
money they keep too much money that is a
perfectly reasonable concern the other
side of it though is that it's insanely
expensive and difficult to work and try
those cases it can take years millions
of dollars dozens of lawyers to finish
some of these huge cases against big
tobacco against companies like Dupont
and others and the lawyers working on
those cases are working on a contingency
meaning they might work for years and
end up making no money so it is true
that in exchange for that risk many of
those attorneys are well compensated
without a doubt but understand that were
it not that way who is even going to be
able to try these cases so the long and
short of it is the more that so-called
tort reform succeeds the fewer legal
remedies that consumers and everyday
people will find themselves with so that
is the back story there's a new name
that has entered this tort reform game
and the name is Suzanne Spalding and
she's doing everything she can to make
it more difficult to hold corporations
accountable she's going after the
lawyers who do exactly this type of work
Suzanne Spalding has become the next
step in the evolution of corporate
attacks on lawyers and Spalding has done
something that in a sense is pretty
slick like I have to hand it to her
instead of the normal attacks these
lawyers are ambulance Chasers tort
reform blah blah blah she has shifted to
these lawyers are spreading
disinformation they're spreading
disinformation she says and I'll explain
what what it is
Suzanne Spalding is a senior advisor at
the center for strategic and
International Studies sounds pretty
pretty legit right the story she's been
telling
is that the lawyers who criticize the
Judiciary
are perpetuating a form of
disinformation when lawyers say hey
here's a judge who's compromised in some
way by political influence here's a
court that's in the pocket of big
businesses Suzanne Spalding says the
lawyers are wrong for saying that
because they're eroding confidence in
the justice system well maybe we should
be questioning the justice system nope
that's disinformation
many of you know Mike papantonia one of
the biggest trial lawyers in the country
I've done shows before from his
conference in Las Vegas once or twice a
year he has a show called America's
lawyer the show used to be on RT as were
the shows of many people who eventually
realized RT is really bad news this
includes Pap it includes our friend Tom
Hartman and others who eventually pulled
pulled the plug on RT which was 100 the
right thing to do so anyway America's
lawyer is an online show now and they
talk about holding the Judiciary
accountable biased judges corporations
that are intertwined with the Judiciary
all of it and by its nature Suzanne
Spalding says oh those that's that type
of commentary is disinformation as
accurate as it might be nope
disinformation bad for the country which
is very very dangerous stuff now lots of
this stuff is quite newsworthy Mike
papantonio was the lead litigator
when the C8 Dupont case came to trial
and we talked about that over The
Dumping of chemicals into a tributary of
the Ohio River many such examples well
it came through to me that through these
think tanks they're always innocuously
named the center for strategic and
international studies and others
this is the line of attack now it all
sounds very official but the closer you
look you realize it's all associated
with corporations and Suzanne Spalding
and csis are singling out Pap and trial
lawyers more broadly and it turns out
csis is funded by the Smith Richardson
Foundation Bank of America Northrop
Grumman the defense contractor BP in the
oil industry the Koch Foundation it's
all The Usual Suspects and they are
weaponizing this method of attacking
lawyers understand that if they were to
succeed they take away mechanisms for
people to hold corporations accountable
that's the that's the impact if they
were to succeed so going after the trial
lawyers is the wrong approach the better
approach would be
hey let's fix the ways in which the
Judiciary is actually compromised let's
fix this interplay revolving door
between the corporations and the
Judiciary and courts and Regulators now
that's not the lawyers are the
disinformation that's exactly the wrong
approach and we all just need to be
aware of if these folks succeed it will
be more difficult for those wronged by
corporations to really hold those
corporations accountable